what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch
episode two of brooklyn nine nine today
if you guys did not see our reaction for
episode one that is of course
up here on the channel excited to go
into this really love that pilot guys if
you haven't done so please hit that like
button helps get this video promoted
subscribe
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction to the next
brooklyn 99 episodes up or something
just pops up that we've covered that
you're like yeah i wonder what you know
how
a subscribe button works full length
watch long where you stick up with the
time code is over at our patreon page
over there we cover many shows where at
the same tier you get the options for
both
reaction highlights and watch logs
included these thumbnails are just a
sliver of what we actually cover over
there and also gotta thank pratham
jindal for editing these reaction
highlights for us
you have been a wonderful extension of
the channel
anywho let's get into this guys
you're three minutes late peralta oh
come on really i'm a few minutes late so
you're going to call me out in front of
everyone
good idea everyone no the other round
let's start with the kristoff murder
it's an amazing solve i got him to
confess in 20 minutes you also
mislabeled the evidence so that
confession
is worthless if the sergeant hadn't
caught your mistake here are three cases
with sloppy paperwork
here are two pictures one is your locker
the other
is a garbage dump in the philippines
[Laughter]
[Music]
that one's the dump they're both you're
locked
[Laughter]
also who cares about all these rules i
have more felony arrests than any other
detective here you also have more mice
living in your desk than any other
detective
algernon's back get rid of the mouse and
get your act together
now he's grumpy
[Music]
i really hope they don't get rid of that
mouse me too
that mouse should be in the opening
credits where are we with the j
street drug bust there are 12 keys of
coke unaccounted for but we just got a
warrant to search the dealer's apartment
good peralta brief us on the vandalism
case well there's no easy way to put
this sarge
but someone has been painting wieners on
squad cars
and apparently i'm gonna plant a decoy
squad car as bait
meanwhile i'll be waiting in an
undercover vehicle here
he's already tagged three uc vehicles
you can clearly spot him you should take
my minivan
it's a good idea sergeant we'll take the
van sir with all due respect i don't
need backup
it's not backup it's babysitting ea in
art history from brooklyn college
interesting huh how's that interesting
well it's surprising because you would
think he had studied
drugs
[Laughter]
you're looking for some missing drugs as
it turns out my friend here carlene is a
psychic
i do palms tarot and i have a degree in
numerology from the internet
really the drugs are in a location i see
the color blue
c's blue and yellow and i see the letter
l r s t w e n b
thank you carlene your entire life is
garbage
oh ouch okay my granny also had
the gift she was on agents of
shield that's why the one you work with
the scary one with the black hair
rosa yes she doesn't love you back she
will never love you back
say thank you charlie
you left without me you were late again
well i had to put on my undercover
minivan disguise
i'm just concerned that you may find it
hard to pursue a criminal on foot
while wearing man's handles but the
sandals define
harvey he's a sandals guy captain why
the babysitting why are you
micromanaging me you think i want to be
sitting here with you instead of running
my precinct yes
it was a rhetorical i've spent the last
12 years
fighting for my first command and i'm
not going to let you screw it up because
you refused to take your job seriously
hey i do take my job seriously i put
away bad guys that's what matters well
so does doing your paperwork showing up
on time
wearing proper footwear no it's on
harvey it's not me well so here's the
deal
you're gonna have a superior officer
babysitting you on every one of your
cases and when you show me that you can
do your job
every part of your job perfectly then
i'll back off from this point on i'll do
every part of the job
perfect perfecter than perfectly quick
update on the tagger situation he is
currently spray painting
ah you knew it you knew it lost the
sandals
i'm here you're busted
i already got it we got em three
bedrooms
why does every perp have a nicer place
than i do you know what they don't teach
you at the academy
it's better to be a criminal oh wow the
cabinets are blue
tacky not a deal-breaker though i just
repaint it the psychic predicted drugs
would be found in something blue
and if she's right about where we find
the drugs that means she's right about
the other thing
uh-huh kitchen
whoa jackpot
you're weird
i feel like rosa likes him that's the
sense i get
what's your name my name is
bananafartmanmd i don't believe you
are you a minor how old are you 610 a
highlander
okay you know what i'm gonna put that in
there and then you're gonna be tried as
an adult highlander and they're gonna
cut your head
could be only one
you're gonna cut your head up
no way she's never wrong we found the
cocaine behind a green hamper
never said green or the letter h she
said blue and yellow charles i don't
know if there's any kindergartners
present but those two colors combined
make green she also mentioned the
letters l
and b and another name for a hamper
is lady bin
a laundry basket
you're gonna be depressed over there
you're bumming out my boy
hey look at this your prince we're on
file
nice to meet you trevor podolski ah
podolski just like uh deputy police
commissioner podolski
your father is deputy police
commissioner podolsky
oh i'm not sure how things work here
but does that mean that your career is
in my hands oh
no you dick
[Laughter]
oh no his decision to target cop cars
makes a lot more sense now
we gotta let him walk right he defaced
nine police vehicles and you kind of
red-handed why would you let him walk
captain i did all the work on this
perfectly i mean
my report has over 25 pages of
meticulous research diagrams and maps
i even put in about the author section
i told you to do every part of your job
and making this call
is part of your job well if i do the
deputy commissioner could ruin my career
and i'll end up on the streets selling
my beautiful body for a can of beans
mm-hmm you were totally right about the
cocaine
and you were also right about rosa don't
get out of the chair
i just had a vision of you leaving this
chair and getting seriously injured oh
my god
i should probably wheel you back to your
desk that is a great
will ya off a bridge i'm kidding oh
you're alone
oh was she so mean i don't know
he's the sweetest hey everyone
hey jake there's a very sexy angry
official here oh no commissioner
podowski he's asking for you
very angry elderly sexy
furious well what vet actor do they get
deputy commissioner where's my son he is
at my desk
trevor what'd you do this time nothing
there you have it he said he did nothing
so i caught him red-handed doing nothing
i'm saying maybe it's a possibility he
made a mistake you do realize
he did thousands of dollars worth of
property damage though
to police vehicles look i think we can
all agree
that i'm ordering you to let this slide
because nothing happened
this is officially out of your hands
would you actually mind
just checking out my report i'll get
right to it have a good one
come on man shoot the kid kill him
cut his head off make an example out of
him in front of everyone that's the
chair
um carlene predicted if i get out of
this chair
i'd get badly hurt so i'm not chancing
it
oh ah there now you're hurt in this
chair you get hurt anywhere boyle
and if you do it won't be because some
shoe salesman predicted it
you make your own destiny kiss her you
cool
we don't have to worry about podolski's
son anymore the case is officially out
of my hands no charges filed
why is there yogurt on this the deputy
commissioner threw my report in terry's
trash can
and he'd been eating yogurt earlier
terry loves yogurt
[Laughter]
his daddy comes in and bails him out
every time he's a lucky little jerk
what kind of father cares so little for
a son that he lets him get away with
everything
someone else's problem now like you said
he's out of your hands
oh my god you could learn something all
right i see what you're trying to do but
it's not gonna work
i'm not gonna arrest him i'm going to
arrest him back up
yes yes you are back
yeah riding surprise perfect
you can't do this get that thing out of
here excuse me sir
trevor podolski you're under arrest for
vandalism and destruction of property
what are you doing i told you to back
off per often first off the name
santiago
detective amy
[Laughter]
i can make your life miserable
commissioner please don't talk to my
detective in that tone you have a
complaint you can take it up with me
i'm going to be watching you both of you
like a hawk you can have to try a little
harder if you want to scare me i've been
an openly gay cop since 1987. so you're
not the first
superior officer to threaten me you know
how i'm still standing here
because i do my job and i do it right
damn son
yeah damn
son
let's get this meeting started i'm not
late i'm here
what right on time
you have a unibumper road baby steps
captain
there's that lady okay there's someone
to get in the joker
okay it's okay we got there eventually
what a necessary show in our lives right
oh i feel
so much better inside about being alive
clearly jon and i were suffering today
this
day it was a day this day would never
ended now
in brooklyn came
in the form of a charming situation
coming
it's funny-ass stuff absolutely so seen
by seeing easter egg break down
mystery solved on the board behind
peralta
all those different names are the
different parts of new york
that's uh it's interesting having to
cover it because like
see on john and i and then was like we
feel like we gotta review everything
gotta break down every major significant
aspect of the episode we had to do that
with a comedy
it was really funny and i enjoyed it
that's the thing is like
i i mean i feel like i've had some
decent practice with psych because like
it's a comedy although that's 45 minutes
worth so they get
you a lot whereas 20-minute comedy is a
little bit like
yeah man it was really funny jokes the
chemistry between the characters the
situation at hand
for them to overcome but i i like the
build up though
of this guy possibly being a villain the
commissioner yeah yeah
because the first like half of the
episode i was like all right this is
cute
charlie i wasn't worried that the show
was gonna suck but i was like okay you
know
it's the second episode after a powerful
pilot and you know that feeling of where
the second episode is not feeling as
strong but like like after like the six
minute mark
is yes like
it was pretty great it was pretty great
again it really just keeps coming back
to andy sandberg and andre brauer like
the of how you feel the shaping of how
he is becoming the father figure
to andy samberg here like andy sandberg
is just like he's a skilled cop but he's
still
learning how to be an adult he doesn't
know how to adult and he's got a man
who's had to deal
with so many struggles all his life who
was going to whip him into shape and
like that chemistry and him having to
make those uh
tough decisions going against the
decisions she normally would have made
in the past like
i love the growth of these two of their
dynamics like that's still to me it
seems like that is
evidently the heart of this show all
right just in the second episode that's
clearly the core of what's going to make
this show work oh yeah
the side stuff though i didn't love that
part as much i enjoyed it i feel like
some of these jokes will probably get
better
or like the situational comedy around
them like terry crews and his wife
uh just his general data i like i like
the idea of like not
seeing his wife but yeah there's just
always this off-camera presence
even just the phone call at the end was
enough to make a punchline or if he's
like intimidated by her to a
certain extent who's the receptionist
though chelsea peretti isn't she married
to jordan peele
i think she is yeah yeah yeah uh
i'm not i don't know how to feel about
her character yet there's something a
little bit off about her character to me
she's like
such a wild card she's so kooky and i'm
waiting to be endeared
like she doesn't look like she does her
job at all
because that's like the redeeming
quality about some of the other wacky
areas of these other characters even
right down to i'm trying to remember
everyone's names uh the
boyle character uh charles uh i'm trying
to act like i'm not quickly picking up
names from an imdb list right over here
to our left
i'll spend the rest of the review like
this but the character of boyle
like he is such a wacky character but
you can still see that he knows how to
do his job and he's good at it
and he gets involved whereas with the
gina character
like where's she just like how did how
does she have a joke
how do you skate by when it's like eddie
sandberg's getting i mean granted i
guess you're not a field operative or a
field cop
you know yeah at the same time it is to
the degree where i'm waiting for them to
add a character layer or something that
endears me to her because like
there are definitely moments of hers
that i've found funny across these two
episodes but she is a character
that i haven't embraced or or like
warmed to past the point where i'm like
oh yeah i love this character
also as part of the ensemble i'm very
much endeared by rosa
and boyle and uh like there's something
there where
i don't know if she's into him or not i
don't i actually don't know
you know she could just be because she's
kind of like up and down with her
emotions and how she
reacts to things yeah i like what
they're doing with toying with the
audience
because it just seems like there's no
way in hell she would be into him but
then there's these little moments where
it's like
she seems like she's probably into him
but i just i have no
i have no real clue she is yeah like is
this an affection more befitting of like
a big
sister or is there some kind of romantic
spark there actually that they're
just both so different that it's hard to
actually get out and touch upon
because yeah i mean there are some
really nice little subtle moments like i
thought it was really sweet
the way she's the one to pull him out of
the chair yeah exactly
i i do think that there's like this i
like the surprise
clever writing that will come through
once in a while like i i
really loved how the second you find out
this guy is the son of the commissioner
you're like okay this is a real dilemma
for him to be in
and then when captain holt is saying
like man dad who just lets him get away
whatever he wants huh that's reflecting
onto peralta
yeah and also the the wrap up the tie
around with
them working together how it starts off
with i don't need backup i'm not backup
i'm babysitting you
to then when heat when then peralta
makes the the tough choice
then he goes do you want backup yeah i
think that's like really great writing
that's
like solid crisp writing yeah their
whole rapport i mean and you touched on
it at the beginning it is the heart and
soul but i think it also is a big driver
of what works both in terms of
character development and character
comedy because when they're not on the
same page
you get a lot of great foil and straight
man type of things or you know straight
man and broad comic character type of
things
and then when they are on the same page
you can see that growth and that bond
starting and so
it's just as fun to watch them be at
odds it seems like as it is to watch
them actually start to rub off on each
other in a positive way
right right all right guys well brooklyn
nine and nine what do y'all
think just say whatever you want give
whatever feedback you i don't know what
to ask when you guys have probably
already seen the whole
show leave your thoughts down below in
any capacity you want i don't care what
you
say subscribe click the notification
bell hit that like button just because
you know what comment helps the
engagement of the video and helps this
video get promoted you know what i mean
page
andrew hayes andrew my dude
if there's anyone at our patreon page
who makes us laugh consistently whenever
we
talk it was you and also
i would say that between who's left in
the month to become a cop
who could become a cop one day it's
andrew absolutely you would be one
actually feels like
he would fit in with like this type of
cop
show you know absolutely andrew
andrew wouldn't put up with crap but he
would be a very fun
personality if you don't rub him the
wrong way and he's from jersey
yeah yeah so just one stone's throw away
from brooklyn come on man in jersey
there's gotta be even more crime
so you got your work cut out for you new
york
you know you're gonna have way more
crime insurance then
it's a good place to practice new jersey
for when you finally do
move to cleaning up the mean streets of
new york we need you buddy and those
luck
how are you andrew just tell us how
you're doing just comment
and tell us how your day has been i miss
you i miss talking to you
and uh next time you're out in cali with
your equally
tall mom you let us know they are the
same
they are the same remember when we met
her we met her at the el portal
you guys were the same height dude that
was that was the ice breaker
and it wasn't you're the singer it was
you guys
you guys
[Laughter]
tallest patron here